pour la première fois en deux ans des
centaines de finissantes en sciences
infirmières de l'université de montréal
ont eu droit à une collation des grades
en personne cette année au québec elles
sont
2758 tous niveaux d'études confondues à
rejoindre le réseau de la santé
ont appuyé tout au long de mon parcours
au baccalauréat
ça s'est bien passé
l'intérêt pour la profession aurait
bondi l'université observe une hausse de
10% de ses demandes d'admission est
vraiment une fille elle trouve espère
que la pandémie est peut-être venu
réveiller chez certains de nos étudiants
le côté de dire voici moi aussi je veux
contribuer mais actuellement le monde
des dernières demeures ap le ministre de
la santé sur les quatre mêmes qu'on
cherche à leernes 2013 qui sont des
jeunots mais on n'en prend plus alors il
ya aussi des choses qu'on veut améliorer
c'est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
vient aussi avec la profession donc on
s'attend des fois des surcharges de
travail comme moi je suis allé un peu
ouvert
avec dans le fossat en tête à la
profession mais ça m'a peut-être
découragé
oui
mais oui mais je pense qu on est
beaucoup aussi dans l'espoir qu'ils
aient les conditions s'améliorent qui je
pense que pour ça ça va en prendre la
relève justement qui est d'apprendre aux
gens et c'est oui on est passionné on
aime ça mais je pense que on a aussi
besoin d'avoir devant des améliorations
l'ordre des infirmières du québec note
une diminution de 7% du nombre des
fermières qui décroche un diplôme entre
2019 et 2021 on va suivre sort mais on
est pauvre on n'est pas inquiet ça
demeure encore très attractif la
profession une super profession mais
encore faut-il lui donner des conditions
d'exercice des conditions de travail la
seconde chance pour patricia conrad qui
pratique depuis une quarantaine d'années
en ch et elle dit l'accompagnement des
nouvelles et dernières est crucial pour
les retenir dans le réseau de la santé
je pense que les jeunes graduée ont
besoin de sentir pour celles qui sont
déjà dans le réseau un appui une
entraide un esprit d'équipé certains
mots tu auras
ici gabriel proulx radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]